I think I wrote you an email and you
also told us that you were aware that
Marc Maron who's a comedian and he does
the WTF podcast was either introduced to
your film flight from death or he was
recommended it was right recommended to
him because it's a theme and it was a
topic that he was interested in how does
that for you to know that you have
someone who's an influencer themselves
who's influenced by your work or
possibly will be once they see it yeah I
mean it's such an honor that someone
like Marc Maron would even be mentioning
the film on his show I let alone be
influenced by it or be moved by it you
know that's that's kind of the things
that's what you hope for when you
complete a film you hope that it takes
on a life of its own and and finds its
way into the lives of people influencers
and connectors and whatnot and you hope
that the kind of word gets spread beyond
kind of your target audience and so yeah
I'm just so honored and so grateful that
he even mentioned it on the show but
yeah you know it makes you feel good
makes you feel like you did something
right you know when you're doing movies
documentaries in particular it's such a
long process and you don't know people
are going to care at the end of it all
and it's kind of terrifying you know
like you pour your life into something
and your whole identity becomes
intertwined with this project and it's
you know you'd be devastated if people
did they hated it you know you'd be
devastated if it didn't go beyond your
living room or your mom's DVD player you
know what I mean it's like it's a scary
it's a scary process and so yeah when
you hear stories like that someone
mentioned some of the podcast where
there's like a million people listening
it's like and that's sweet that's
awesome yeah do you remember a time that
you've reached out to an artist to
congratulate them on their work let them
know that it inspired you to heaven
no i don't okay I don't think I have
yeah no I'm sorry I never sent an email
or letters long I don't think so well I
mean there was you know when i was 16 i
wrote a letter to my favorite ninja um
he was a star of a lot of these ninja
movies his name is show Kazuki he was
pretty awesome and I brought to him he
sent a picture back autographed photo
fairy he's like a real life ninja too oh
wow okay pretty cool
you